hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar optimizing tumor study
performance evaluating the bndg
and nsg models in pdx and cdx tumor
studies
i am kayleigh bach of labrutz and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by invigo
to learn more please visit invigo.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting as many questions you may
have during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd now like to welcome our speaker dr
victoria hidmark
senior scientist at invigo
victoria you may now begin your
presentation
thank you so much for that introduction
and thank you for to everybody online
who has joined in today
uh as mentioned i will be presenting on
optimizing tumors study performance
evaluating the bdng and nsg models in
pdx and tumor studies
so an overview of today's presentation i
will start with going over
an overview of how the bndg model was
created and some of its characteristics
then we will look at some humanization
data utilizing uh pbmcs and hscs
in the
bndg model
and then for the meat of the
presentation we'll look at
how the bndg model performs in
supporting the growth of tumor cell
lines
as well as patient-derived sonographs
and how
the growth rate compares
between the bndg model and the nsg model
but starting out with the model creation
it's character and some characteristics
so the bntg model or the not
cb17 prairie kdc skid il-2r
gamma tm1
bcghsd
model was created by biocytogen
through the leading the il-2r gamma or
common gamma chain gene
in the non-cb17 skid mouse and this
model has subsequently been licensed by
indigo
so the nod cb17 skidmice
already had the prkdc null mutation
which is characterized by
these mice having a deficiency in
functional tmb cells
and addition
the deletion of the il-2r gamma
results in a further immunodeficiency
due to a lack of functional receptors
for a wide array of cytokines for
example il-15
which is essential for the development
of functional and k-cells
so
the way that il2r gamma gene was deleted
in the bndg model was through crispr
cast 9 technology utilizing crispr cas9
technology and the entire coding region
so exons one through eight
were all deleted and there was no
back crossing
needed to generate the model
so this is different from
other models such as the
nsg model where
the ielts or gamma delete
gene deletion was generated and then had
to be back crossed
onto the model
so carrying on with some of the features
of the bndg model
we have looked at its growth in both
male and female
both males and females and this was a
study that was carried out
uh in-house
in one of our production facilities in
france
and so 30 males and 30 females were
utilized for the study and their weights
were measured over a time period of 10
weeks
and as you can see here at six weeks the
average weight of one of these
managing females is
about 19. 19.9 grams which is slightly
smaller
than what's been seen in the nsgs where
the average weight of this age is about
21.1 grams so not a big difference but
something that could possibly
reduce the cost of compounds in
long efficacy studies where the mice are
dosed daily based on their body weight
so
as i mentioned this model is
triple immunodeficient adding to the
models that are
on the market
displaying this phenotype um and this
has been shown to enhance tumor cell and
graftman and we will look at some of
some of this data later on in the
presentation as well
so a triple immune deficiency that means
it has
no t cells no b cells and as i mentioned
these mice are also deficient in in ak
cells
this model also so decreased weakness as
the animals ages compare to other skin
models
and as it was generated on the nod
background
uh it does have the nod surf alpha
polymorphism which has been
shown to
facilitate engraftment with both pbmcs
and
hscs so
biocytogen
performed some of these humanization
experiments
utilizing the bndg mice and they did
this using both human
peripheral blood mononuclear cells and
hematopoietic stem cells
so here we see some data from
the study done utilizing pbmcs
and so for this study um there was three
mice utilized they were injected with
um
five million uh pbmcs into their caudal
veins and then 26
days or sorry 24 days after the
injection
they looked at how
many mouse
cd45 positive cells were
present compared to how many uh humans
see the 45 positive cells and as you can
see here
the frequency of human cd5 positive
cells range from 36
about 36 percent up to 73
taking a closer look at this um
human cd45 positive cell in particular
and then um
gating utilizing cd19 and cd3 so b-cell
and t cell markers
you can see that
essentially all of these human cd45
positive cells are also positive for cd3
as mentioned they also did humanization
studies utilizing cd33 positive hscs and
so for these studies
the bndg mice were injected iv with a
hundred thousand of these human
hematopoietic stem cells after
radiation
and then they tracked the frequency of
these human cd5 positive cells
over time and that is what we can see
here on the left
on the left-hand side so after two weeks
after injection
the percentage of human cd45 positive
cells
is less than 20
but after eight weeks
um at least 70 percent of the mice have
more
um than 80 percent uh human cd45
positive cells
taking a closer look at what cell
populations are represented within this
cd45 positive or human city 45 positive
cell population
they further show that 49
are t cells
about 25 are b cells and the nk cells
make up about two percent of this
population
so together these two studies
demonstrate that the bndg
mice can be humanized utilizing both
pbm seats and hscs and that it thus can
provide a very valuable tool
for
immuno oncology research
but naturally in order
to be able to do immunocollege research
the mod the mouse model also has to
support the growth of tumors
so that is what we will focus on
for the remainder of the presentation
and we will start looking at how
the bndg model can be used as a tool for
cdx studies
um so it's been shown that the bndg
model supports engraftments of a wide
array of tumor lines and it has so far
been referenced in nearly 20
peer-reviewed studies
and these studies include
cancer
silence derived from cancers of
different tissues
and for a total of 21 different cell
lines
so
you can see
in this table right here that these vary
from blood cancers to epithelial cancers
to brain cancers
looking closer at a data set generated
by one of our collaborator collaborators
crown
bio
they
compared the growth of the leukemia cell
line kasumi 1
between bndgs and nsg mice so here 10
animals were used per group and 10
million cells
were injected per mouse and for this
particular cell lines
there was a faster tumor growth in the
bndg miles compared to the nsg mice with
the end point reached about
nine to ten days sooner in the bneg
compared to the nsg
another collaborator xenopath which was
based in spain utilized a non-small cell
lung cancer
deadline for a cdx study and
for this they compared the growth in
bnd gmis versus the azimuth nude mice
and as you can see here
in the red
the bndgs
supported the growth of this cell line
very well
whereas it grew much slower in the less
a thymic newtonians
so these data demonstrate that the bnd
gnd can be a very valuable tool for
carrying out cdx studies in particular
for cell lines
that
have a very slow growth so that does not
grow into less immunodeficient models
another area that we know
[Applause]
these ultra immunodeficient models
generally perform
better or
phrasing it differently are known to
support faster
tumor growth
and also the engraftment of more
models is for the patient-derived
xenograph studies
so for
those of you who are not familiar uh
with this
terminology whereas a cdx or a cell cell
line-derived cenograft is um generated
from
a tumor cell line
these p which have been grown which can
or have been grown in culture
a pdx model is generated
by grafting
a patient tumor sample and then
putting this straight into a mouse model
and never growing these
tumor cells
in vitro and this has been shown to
better demonstrate
or better recapitulate the
inter-terminal heterogeneity that is
seen
in patient tumors
but it is also known that
these types of tumor models tend to be
harder to grow
in mouse models compared to a lot of the
selling based models
so
we wanted to look how the bndg model
supported these as well
so biocytogen had
has generated some
some of these models
in the bnd in fact they have been able
to and graft 173 different pdx models
uh in the bndg mouse and these are from
cancers arising from various tissues
and you can see the breakdown
in this figure where the majority was
from gastric cancer but there was also
long pancreatic blood breast colorectal
and esophageal cancers
there's also been literature published
where the bndg mouse has been utilized
in order to
grow these pdx
models
in the table here you see three
different examples
where
there is a pub
study published
utilizing a small small cell lung cancer
pdx colorectal cancer pdx
as well as an intra-hepatic calendar
pdx model
but we also wanted to perform some of
these studies in-house and also compare
how our ultra-immunodeficient png model
compared to that of the
nsg mouse
so to do this we utilized four different
uh pdx models uh from two different
collections that are licensed by
ambigo so we utilize three different
breast cancer pdx models from the
washington university human and mouse or
wim
breast cancer pda
pdx collection
so this is a collection of over 100
models
where
the patient clinical outcome therapeutic
history and responsiveness to treatment
is documented
and for some of these models we also
have additional characterization data
available that we are um
happy to share in order for our clients
to be able to
pick the ideal models
and to generate
the data that they need
so
we have
exome and whole genome sequencing
reverse phase protein array rna-seq
nanostring data standard of care
efficacy study data growth rate data and
gene expression data available for some
of our
for some of these pdx models we also
utilized one
melanoma pdx model which is a part of
the wistar
minimum pdx model collection
and envigo has licensed about 150 of
these models which are available through
the vistar institute
and we have seven of these models
readily available at studies and
distribution at embico
so these models
include braf
resistant models which is obviously a
very important tool in order to develop
new therapies
for patients that carry brf persistent
tumors
we also have some characterization data
available for these models such as the
primary tumor type
what targeted therapy
this tumor saw prior
to the grafting of the sample to
generate the pdx
as well as if
they received any immune therapy and if
so which one uh prior to biopsy
we also know the age and gender the
biopsy site site and the stage of the
tumor
and some limited
mutation information
so the outline of these studies where
the female mice were implanted
subcutaneously with a single uh cell
suspension of the pdx so
so wim 5 wimp 20 wim 3 which is
which are the breast cancer pdx models
utilized
or wm4071-2
which is the
melanoma pdx model
we utilized
at a 1.5 million cells per mouse
the cells were mixed
in 1-1 with pbs and matrigel
and the total injection volume was 100
microliter per mouse so for the
duration of the study these house mice
were housed in about individually vented
cages and consumed teclad global rodent
diet 29
19.
and these tumors were measured using the
biopticon tumor imager
and volumes we're calculating using the
corresponding tumor manager software
so in the subsequent
graphs i will show you
i just want to let you know that for the
mean tumor volume graphs
once a tumor reached the 200 millimeter
cube size the mouse was removed from the
study and so that data is no longer
plotted
so the first pdx model will utilize
is called wim 5 and that is a triple
negative breast cancer model that was
derived from a brain metastases of a
very aggressive tumor
it is p53 mutant
and for this particular model uh the
whole uh
genome sequence data has been published
and we'll be happy to provide that
for clients that are interested
for model
selection purposes there's also rna-seq
data and gene expression data
in addition to the clinical data
so looking at the results from this
study
at the top you see spider plots so this
is where each individual line represents
the tumor growth on one mouse
and
the graph on the bottom and then instead
shows the mean
uh tumor volume for the entire group
and as you can clearly see in particular
in the bottom graph
this pdx model grew with the same rate
in the nsg
and bnd mouse
mice but it grew much slower in the less
immunodeficient ethymic nude mouse
the second pdx model that we tested was
the wim 20 model again from the
wim collection from washington
university
and this is an er and pr positive model
that is her2 negative it is derived from
skin metastases
and it has been shown to have the y537s
esr1
mutation and it is also a
mute has mutation for p53 and pic3ca
as for wind5 we have whole genome
sequence data rna-seq data
and gene expression data available in
addition to the clinical data
so looking at how this tumor grew
in the ultra immunity deficient compared
to each other as well as to the azimuth
atheist mouse
as you can see the overall growth rate
in all models was much slower than the
wim
and the triple negative wim 5 model
but again we see that there is no
statistical difference in the growth
rate of these of this pdx model in the
nsg mice compared to the bnd gmis
but that again
this pdx model
grows
slower
in the less immunodeficient a thymic
nude mass model
so the final
breast cancer pdx model we tested was
wim 43
so this is an er positive
pr positive and her2 positive
tumor derived from the right from a
right rib metastasis
it carries the
d538g
esr1 mutation
but it's wild type for both p53 and p3ca
for this model we do have exome
sequencing data in addition to rna-seq
and gene expression data
and clinical outcome data
so with the risk of sounding repetitive
we saw the same pattern
for this
the pdx model where
the tumors grew with similar rates in
both the
nsgs and the bndgs
but where they grew much slower
in the
less immunodeficient
athymic nude mouse
so moving into the final
tumor model that we tested which
to remind you of what's the melanoma
model so the wm4071-2
model
this is the braf resistant model
which has the v 600k
mutation
and it is derived from a brain
metastasis
and the patient from which this was
derived was treated with with
memoraphenib prior to sample collection
so as we saw for all the three
breast cancer pdx models we tested
this melanoma
grew uh with similar rates in both the
bndg as well as
nd nsg mice
however clearly different was how these
um
this pdx model performed in the
nude mice as you can see here
essentially all the three groups
um
show similar tumor growth
uh with this
pdx models whereas
in the breast cancer pdx we tested the
ultra immunodeficient
mouse models both supported much faster
growth
so together we can take
this data
and say that
depending on what model
you're utilizing
these ultra immunodeficient mice can
really shorten on your study time
but depending on
what model you're using or what compound
you're using
and how long
that compound needs to be
be utilized for treatment in order to
see an effect
you know different models
different mouse models will
be able to support different types of
studies
um
so
as i mentioned we are very excited to be
able to add the bndg model into the
repertoire of immunodeficient mouse
models that we
can provide for our clients and that
they can purchase in order to utilize
for their
tumor studies
but
we can also offer
services to perform
efficacy studies
in-house adam vigo
and um
we
are happy to perform these uh studies in
the mouse model
of your choice um but again we're
excited to be able to
add the bndg model to as an option
so in general
in order to get
be able to get
statistical differences between the
groups we
like to have at least eight to ten mice
per group
and uh we do implant fifty percent more
mice with tumor cells than we know we
will be needing to enroll for a study
and this is just to ensure that we have
a sufficient amount of mice with tumors
within the correct
size requirements in order to be able to
enroll
all mice
at a single enrollment event
so for these studies again
we as we did for this
pediatric studies
i just showed you some data from we do a
single cell
an implantation of single cell
suspension
sub q on the right flank
and we perform str analysis both prior
to implantation as well as at the end of
the study
to confirm
the model
we can offer
ivip oral and subcu dosing of a single
compound as well as combination group
as well as compound formulation services
and
these
as for the
pdx
studies i showed you data from we
measure these tumors using the tumor
imager and corresponding tumor
manager software
um and provide weekly updates to our
clients so that any
needed adjustment can be be done quickly
we also can provide end of study body
samples and tumor tissue so
you know allowing
the clients to extrapolate as much
information as possible
from each study and from each individual
animal
and we'll also provide a final stutter
report
complete with
all the dose volumes and weights
together with the tumor volumes
throughout the entirety of the study
we can also
offer tolerability studies that can be
performed in mice with or without
tumors
and as well as pkpd studies
where these can often be performed in
those extra mice that were implanted but
that was not enrolled in an efficacy
study
to reduce
price
and you know we
pride ourselves in excellent customer
service and flexibility we really want
to work with our clients
to
pick the best tumor model the best mouse
model and the best study design
for their
study goal
um so in conclusion
uh the bndg model
was developed by a cyanogen using crispr
cas9 and call
technology
and this
new ultra immunocompromised mouse model
is a great addition to the field of
oncology research in particular for the
harder to grow
or slower growing
cell lines and patient-derived xenograft
models
i've further shown that the bndg model
can be humanized utilizing both
pvmcs as well as hscs
and that they can that these mice can
support the growth of a wide array of
tumor cell lines as well as pdx models
and that um
for for the models that we looked at
they do so with very similar kinetics to
that of the nsg mouse
and then as i mentioned
if you're carrying out these
long efficacy studies with daily dosing
based on body weight the slightly
smaller size
of the bndg model can help reduce cost
based on compound and feed
and then finally we enable have the
capability to support
to run efficacy studies
in the bndg model or in other mouse
models of your choice
so that concludes my presentation i'll
be happy to have a topic to take any
questions that um
have come in during the presentation
and if anyone watches this
after
the fact or have questions come up after
the presentation
please go ahead and email marketing at
invigo.com and we will be happy to
answer your questions thank you so much
for your time
thank you victoria for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
all right let's get started our first
question asks
can i obtain a license to breed bndgs at
my animal facility
yes that is a great question thank you
so much
so the answer to that is no we cannot
provide breeding licenses for
this model for someone to breed them at
their facility however if you know that
you will be running frequent tumor
studies
and that you will have frequent need for
a certain amount of miles of this model
uh you know we'll be happy to work with
you to set up a custom
reading project of this line
that would be able to supply your needs
great thank you our next question asks
can i find the peer-reviewed articles
utilizing the bndg mouse model on the
indigo website
yes so you can find these um
on two different in two different places
on the website so if you go to the vigo
website and search for the bndg model
if you scroll all the way down to the
bottom uh there will be links that will
take you on to the peer reviewed article
based on different research topics
you can also go to the technical
resources and request to download the
bndg white paper
and there will be
references listed within this white
paper as well
great thank you for that detailed answer
our next question is a little bit longer
and it says
you mentioned that your pdx models
inoculated with single cell suspension
does that mean your patient samples were
cultured in vitro before inoculation it
does not maintain the 3d structure or
heterogeneity
of the original status right
um
so a couple of portions of that question
so when the model was
first or the tumor tissue was first
grafted from the patient
it was taken from the patient and you
know dissociated into tumor fragments
which were later inoculated into the
mouse
for the first round of propagations
in subsequent propagations we take
the tumor
from the mouse
and we dissociate it
using the
methanol dissociation kit and then
freeze down the tumors
and that's what we utilize for the tumor
studies but no these uh these tumors
this tumor cells never see
um the in vitro culture conditions they
go
you know from
patient to mouse or from mouse to mouse
with that interview intervening
dissociation step
wonderful thank you
and it looks like we have time for one
more question here and this one asks do
you see a difference in tumor take rate
between the nsg and the bndg mice
so we have limited data on this
you know based on the four pdx models
that we ran in in-house
and based on those studies no we do not
see
any great differences in um
the tape rate between both of these
ultra immunodeficient
mouse models
wonderful well thank you again victoria
for your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor in vigo for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye